منذ ان حتى الطائر الازرق في قفص
الملياردير ماسك لم تنفك التغييرات تطارد
تويتر اخرها حظر الحسابات المستخدمه
للترويج لمنصات تواصل اجتماعيا اخرى مثل
الفيسبوك وانستغرام ومستدون المنافس
لتويتر خطوه لاقت معارضه واسعه خاصه من
المؤسس المشارك لتويتر جاك دورسي الذي
وصفها بالخطوه التي لا معنى لها القرار
جاء بعد ايام قليله من تعليق حسابات
صحفيين على تويتر بحجه عدم امتثالهم
لسياسته الجديده دوكسينج والمتعلقه بنشر
المعلومات
ومع الضغوط التي تعرض لها وجد ماسك نفسه
امام خيار الطرح استطلاع راي على حسابه
لاعاده تفعيل الحسابات او ابقائها مغلقه
عمليه تعليق الحسابات اثاره غضب الحكومات
والافراد حول العالم معتبرين انها تقويم
لحريه الصحافه وتناقض ما دعى اليه ماسك
نفسه عند استحواده على تويتر
في ظل كل الاحداث المكثفه التي مر بها
تويتر خلال اقل من شهرين من تولي ماسك
المنصب والقيود التي وضعها على المستخدمين
بينما يحاول جعلهم ان يدفعوا مقابل
الخدمات يتجه العديد من المستخدمين الى
منصه اخرى بحسب اكسيوس
ضغوط كبيره خلال فتره قصيره ربما كانت
السبب وراء استطلاع الراي الذي نشره ماسك
على تويتر
متسائلا الى ما كان يجب ان يتخلى عن منصبه
في تويتر ما قد يجعله خارج اسوار المنصه
الاكثر شعبيه الى عمر العربيه